تعد مدينة دامبولا موطنًا
لأكبر مجمع الكهوف وأفضلها الحفاظ عليه
في سريلانكا
[موسيقى]
بينما يوجد أكثر من 80
كهفًا موثقًا في نصف فدان حول
دامبولا ، وهناك خمسة كهوف رئيسية
تجذب معظم الزوار لأن كل من
هذه الكهوف  تحتوي الكهوف على معبد مترامي الأطراف
، صورة متكررة في جميع أنحاء
المجمع هي بوذا ، ويمكن العثور عليها في
شكل تمثال ذهبي يبلغ طوله حوالي 100
قدم ، ويحتوي كهف الملوك على
أكثر من 55 تمثالًا مختلفًا ،
وأكبر تمثال يبلغ ارتفاعه 50 قدمًا في
كهف آخر يوجد سقف  مع وجود
أكثر من 1500 لوحة لبوذا عليها
بالإضافة إلى الوجود المتكرر
لبوذا ، هناك أيضًا تماثيل
وصور لملوك سريلانكا وآلهة وآلهة أخرى في
جميع أنحاء معابد الكهوف
منذ أكثر من 22
قرنًا وفي السنوات الأخيرة
خضعت لجهود الحفاظ على  تأكد من
وجودهم لعدة قرون
قادمة